[Musique]
je suis chanteuse musicienne avant tout
ENF je me considère des fois plus comme
musicienne que comme chanteuse mais je
suis vraiment chanteuse j'ai sorti C
albums à la base je suis guitariste
électrique et mais maintenant mon ma
musique est très électronique aussi j'ai
été attiré par par le fait de chanter à
travers des envies de poésie mais rock
la poésie elle est inhérente à mon
travail je pense que même la poésie
c'est un rapport au monde donc il il se
il transpire dans la dans la façon de
faire la musique euh qui est très
particulière singulière et c'est ça qui
me plaît donc même ma façon de faire de
la musique électronique elle est elle
est poétique finalement euh parfois même
un peu expérimentale et j'assume
complètement euh mais il y a les
mélodies sont très importantes pour moi
donc et c'est très éteré parfois et et
parfois très très
[Musique]
brut e j'attein l'ING je dor l'innocence
retrouvée trembleant moin la douceur la
chaleur de l'été j'ai longtemps parcouru
les vallées
d'infortune tant de prières froides et
Tanis de mes
amertumes
[Musique]
en première partie d'arthurche étant
donné que je suis en finalisation de mon
prochain album qui s'appelle absence je
vais jouer ces morceaux qui sont pas
encore sortis qui sortent le 8 octobre
2024 absence c'est c'est un voyage j'ai
raconté un voyage en plusieurs étapes
chaque chanson est l'étape d'un voyage
hisoire c'est une femme qui fait un
voyage au fond des eos et qui finit
recracher par la mer tout
[Musique]
simplement